Cứ hơn 2 chự đô của 4 nữ ở têning rồi bỏ chốn, bằng cơp lên tục dị truyền từ bắt bảo nám,
khiến hàng trăm cảnh sắp phải lên theo dấu phép xuất ngay đêm.
Tha đều tra, phạm li phương, bà mấy tư tuổi, biết 1 nữ mằng tên từ thành phố chỉ mình xuống tên nhỉ.
Phương cầu kết củang lọc, tấn Anh, duy, lên kế hoại cấp, ngày 1 mùi thằng ba, chúng giả công an đến kìm tra
gồn gốc xuất tên tại nhà nạn nhân, rồi môi lên chủ sở công an làm việc.
Lời dụr sở hợp, nhóm cứ tản bộ tên rồi bỏ chốn.
Thưa ra đầu, măng cước măng tình ra phía bắt sạo liên quyền định cơ sử.
Tế đó, chúng quay lại các tình biên chung tình đường chốn sang lọc học cấp vùi chiếc.
Bình rối bị cạnh sắp phòng qua, chung trẻ hục lên địa bàn tên quyền địa lên chốn.
Ngay 1 thằng ba, cơ quan đổi tra đã bắt sự lên quyền địa tại hản lỗi,
thu dữ gần 2 chự đô là tăng vật của vụ an.
Đến mùi 2 dự chung ai 2 mùi thương thằng ba, bằng í phạm bị bắt khi đang lên chốn tại một lắng trạng ở rất lài.
Công ăn tên liên và cuộc sê hôm hai đặc lễ lời khai các bị cán, một giọc đuổi tra của an.